hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game it's from uh day two of the
uh aimchess u.s rapid preliminaries and
it's the first game of day two it's done
in lardisk versus wesley so and it
features an opening that just keeps on
giving just when you thought you've seen
everything for there is to see from the
real opus a game like this happens it's
incredibly enjoyable uh let's dive
straight into it and it's a it's a
fairly short game so naradiski with the
white pieces opens with e4 we have e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and like we
said uh bishop to b5 the real opus is on
the board we have a6 uh morphy's defense
bishop to a4 and now knight to f6 we
have castles by white and b5 by black
bishop to b3 and this is all very
standard rue lopezian stuff uh so uh i'm
not gonna comment on it uh too much
bishop the c5 uh and d3 now we have d6
and a4 uh black made this expansion on
the queen side a6 b5 so of course we
want to undermine that we have rook to
b8 and now a captures on b5 we have
eight captures and bishop to e3 uh
challenging black's dark square bishop
here we have bishop captures f captures
now white has this doubled e pawn but he
has the semi-open file open for his
rooks and he does have uh control of the
f uh of the f5 square so ideas like
knight h5 to f5 uh will come in very
handy we have castles by wesley and now
queen e1 uh the queen is now guarding
the h4 square as well as it will be very
useful so here uh there are a few games
where bishop to e6 was played countering
white slide square bishop here but here
we have queen the e7 by wesley and it is
now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see how
now this can continues this we have
knight to h4 like we said the knight
wants to come to f5 and you don't have
any discoveries since uh queen to e1 is
guarding the knight on h4 uh and it's uh
well it's uh
uh
you could try playing this in a lot of
different ways for example you could try
bishop to e6 you could try moving the
queen back you could try a lot of stuff
but it it makes sense playing g6 just
preventing the knight from coming to f5
but this also weakens the king side
somewhat and whether this is good or not
it's a hard to say for a rapid game in a
rapid game you don't want to waste too
much time dwelling on such things so
here knight to c3 at some point you will
enjoy bringing your knight to the d5 and
now knight to b4 now both of the knights
are controlling that d5 square we have
queen to g3 developing the queen
connecting rooks and now knights to f5
can be played again because the queen is
pinning the g pawn so here king to g7 uh
now
wesley now wants to move the knight and
push the pawn so he wants to get the
king away from this light square
diagonal we have knights to f5 check uh
and now bishop captures an f5 we have
rook captures on f5 you could also
capture with the e pawn but naruto wants
to bring the outer rook over to f1
double up on the f file and have a lot
of pressure here so here wesley goes
knight to d7 continues with his plan
rook a2f1 and now as the f7 pawn is
attacked a lot of times we have f6 the
knight nicely controls the f6 square
and you don't have to worry about your
king being on on this diagonal
we have knight to d5 now uh attacking
the queen and the knight so knight's
captures on d5 is the only move
knight captures on the e5 bishop
captures and now knight to b6 putting
pressure on this bishop here and now if
this was a classical game you would
probably play something like bishop to
c6 block uh black c pawn from being
pushed anywhere and the white would just
enjoy a very pleasant game but this is
rapid chess and in rapid chess we often
just push stuff so here we have h4 now
preparing h5 and you wanna bust open the
position or maybe even something crazier
as you'll see we have c6 by wesley now
offering up this pawn but not just this
pawn this pawn will can also fall
because he wants to play bishop captures
queen here queen captures on c2 and
queen captures and b2 sort of give up
these two pawns for these two pawns and
he would get to activate his uh queen
and rooks maybe so here uh narudinsky
obliges he plays bishop captures in c6
we have queen to c7 and now bishop
captures on b5 wesley grabs the pawn on
c2 and now h5 so what do you play here
well wesley plays queen captures on b2
that was his intention all along he's
now threatening to capture the bishop on
b5 but there is something dangerous in
the position something very much hidden
uh so feel free to pause the video here
and try to find this incredible move
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting it as
it's really not an easy move to find and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's ponte h6 and this is truly
outstanding because now well uh
obviously we have to ask ourselves what
happens if the king just captures the
pawn well if the king captures the pawn
then we play rook captures on f6 and it
doesn't really matter what black plays
here you could move the king back you
could capture the rook and none of this
works for example you captured the rook
we're gonna play uh a queen to h4 with
check and now your only move is king to
g7 now we capture here with check and
now after king to g8 you think okay now
everything is fine uh he can't really do
anything here if he plays queen to f7
check i'm just going to move the king
away to h8 and there's really no good
way to continue but there come here
comes the bishop to e8 and now there's
the threat of queen to f8 checkmate and
black doesn't really have a reply here
if he captures the bishop it's just
queen to f7 check king moves and now we
capture the rook with czech king g7 and
queen to f8 is checkmate so this is uh
the ugly side of what can happen if you
if you
play rook captures on f6 and another
thing black could try is just going back
with the king king to g7 but this also
doesn't help him all that much because
the simplest solution
will work just fine here queen to f3 and
there's no defense here rook to f7 check
is coming and if you accept this then
we're gonna play rook capture a queen
captures rook and f6 if you move the
king back then the same idea goes bishop
to e8 wins the game like we've just
shown but if king to h6 then it's the
very nice queen to h4 check king g7
queen the e7 check king to h6 and not
rook to f7 and the queen guards the g5
square there is no defense against rook
captures an h7 checkmate or if you
really want to you know try it we could
play it rook to h8 and then queen the h
for his checkmate because the rook
prevents the king from going back to
the g7 uh so this is what happens if the
h6 pawn is captured so pawn to h6 check
is truly a remarkable move uh wesley of
course did not capture it he played king
back to h8 king the g8 is also playable
maybe even a bit more resilient but you
kind of want to avoid the light squares
as white also has a light square bishop
so wesley played king to h8 but now
comes queen to g5 and this is just a
monstrosity of a move uh the point is if
you capture with the rook then that this
really doesn't do anything captures
capture so black will capture the bishop
here and you don't have a good
continuation but here the move narudisky
played queen to g5 is the only move that
wins and this is just uh
spectacular there's no good reply here
if f captures on g5 it's a nice
checkmate rook captures an f8 rook
captures and rook captures his checkmate
as the pawn covers the the g7 square
something that would not be possible if
the king was on g8 like we mentioned but
even that line falls apart very quickly
uh so here of course uh we have queen
captures on b5 and there there's no good
move here all of the moves just end in
checkmate so wesley captured the bishop
hoping for the best but now rook
captures an f6 uh we have rook f the e8
now trying to survive this but now
another shocker here narudisky just
keeps on giving rook captures on g6
and again if you captured the rook it's
not a problem queen to f6 czech king
wherever and now queen to g7 will be
checkmate so after rook captures in g6
wesley tried knight to d7 simply to
prevent queen to f6 check
but now comes rook to g7 and he was in
this position on move 29 that wesley so
resigned the game and the spectacular
victory for daniel narudicki who who is
often on the giving end of of such
brilliancies as
if you've been following the channel so
far whenever we show a naradiski game
it's usually a really really crazy
brilliancy such as this one and none
other than the rui lopez so here you
resign there's not much that can be done
rook captures on h7 is the threat after
king captures queen to g7 will be
checkmate and if you prevent this we can
play queen to e7 now threaten rook to h7
checkmate and now if you block this with
knight to f8 kind of preventing this
it's not a problem just real captures
with check only move king captures and
queen to g7 will be checkmate so
everything here ends in checkmate it's a
spectacular game and it's definitely uh
well an idea that you might enjoy if you
if you you know play play the royal opus
with white try try to play this line
with the double e pawn uh semi-open file
for the rook and then maybe this queen
e1 uh knight stage four to f5 line you
know and good things might happen for
you
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it i i enjoyed it immensely
uh so there's that uh i would like to
thank alan goyet david kimura vladimiro
mark thompson and annie mccain for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
uh very nice tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world uh thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day